et c'est dans ce contexte que les
salariés de l'air onetik gravement au
rap actée par la crise sanitaire vont de
nouveau défilé aujourd'hui en occitanie
hier les salariés d'airbus s'était déjà
mobilisée à l'aéroport de toulouse
blagnac
plus de 7000 personnes ont battu le pavé
contre le plan social de l'avionneur un
plan qui prévoit la suppression de 15000
postes dont 3600 à toulouse
écoutez ces quelques réactions sur place
je dors peu moins bien que d'habitude
mais c'est tout simplement quand on
entend les chiffons se demande si on
sera encore là dans quelques mois et
j'ai une famille j'ai une famille j'ai
ma femme qui est au chômage donc voilà
on l'emploie et d'emploi important pour
ma famille et puis de toute façon je
pense que tous mes collègues c'est un
peu pareil
on est on est là on est là pour
travailler on en a choisi airbus est la
plus mince a choisi
c'est une passion voilà du jour au
lendemain passé de des montées en
cadence à entendre parler d'un plan avec
des milliers de licenciements
c'est un véritable champion tout
simplement pourquoi on est là parce
qu'on ne comprend pas
ces entreprises gèrent l'argent que
l'état leur a versé
donc on parle de milliards pourquoi pas
ça ça nous en plaçons pas - servez voilà
pourquoi on est là aujourd'hui et pour
qu'on va avoir des réponses
combien de procès n'aurait pu maintenir
avec la prime de départ de tom enders de
38,6 millions d'euros combien d'enfants
au maintien avec son gardien voilà moi
je pense qu'il ya deux poids deux
mesures il ya les pétitions qui salariés
il n'y a pas de fatalité à ce que les
salariés